[Music]
one of other Studios in Hollywood it's
the Conan obviousiy Awards celebrating
excellence in the sitting and looking
cars here now is your host Conan O'Brien
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen for a night this
important I think I should dress the
part do you mind
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much thank you
thank you thank you oh look the podium
moves around a piece of [ __ ] there's no
bigger audience or cilantro than this
one right now and look at this award
ladies and gentlemen a lot of money went
into this baby
gorgeous beautifully crafted beautifully
crafted by a child in four minutes
alright let's get started shall we our
first audience award is for the best
impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person in seat
5d for their impression of Breaking
Bad's Aaron Paul that's exciting yeah
[Applause]
very nice
this next audience D award is also for
best impression of a celebrity and the
audience he goes to the person in seat
seven J for their impression of the star
of Jessica Jones Krysten Ritter yeah
Wow the next audience reward is awful
for best impression of a celebrity and
the audience he goes to the person in
seat 16 II for their impression of Groot
[Music]
very good group everyone in the audience
is making mental note never come to this
show again next audience he goes to the
person in seat 15 am it's the award for
the audience member most likely to be
the cool counselor at a Jewish sleepaway
camp
[Applause]
next audience he goes the person in seat
11 K it's the award for the audience
member most likely to be mistaken for
Charles Brown Charlie Brown as an
Armenian nightclub bouncer
[Applause]
oh my god Lord our next audience award
goes to the audience member most likely
to humble brag about this experience on
Facebook and the winner is the person in
seat 11 t for this post so blessed to be
in the audience sees today hard work
really does pay off
hashtag believe hashtag no filter
[Music]
all right our next award goes to the
audience member with the most beautiful
applause that's right the most beautiful
applause and the audience he goes to the
person in seat 10b yeah give us a
demonstration give us a demonstration
No just so we can hear it that's all I
ask
please please no perfect he's really
ashamed to be here yeah really ashamed
to be here yeah she was sure her tickets
said Ellen this next audience he goes to
the best-looking audience member in the
entire crowd that's right yeah and the
award goes to the person in seat 6p yeah
[Applause]
good
thank you I'm glad we all agree that's
fresh paint no award show is complete
without a live cut away to a celebrity
in the audience who isn't looking now we
don't have any celebrities in our
audience so let's go live right now to
an unsuspecting Daniel Radcliffe in his
home it's a camera
what are you doing it
[Music]
[Applause]
our next award our next award is for the
audience member whose high school
yearbook named them most likely to end
up in a TV audience and the audience e
goes to the person in c8 v8v
[Applause]
our next award goes to the person in
seat 14 J let's get a shot of him right
there yeah it's the award for the Cameo
best cameo in the new blockbuster film
Captain America Civil War she clearly
had the best cameo let's check out her
work yeah someone dies on your watch you
don't give up who said we're giving up
we offer not taking responsibility for
our actions
this document just shifts the blame
sorry Steve that that is dangerous this
is the United Nations we're talking
about it's not the Security Council
[Applause]
applause yes everybody yeah
that woman just hates us now and she's
not wrong and finally our last award
will be a special prize for the lucky
audience member sitting in seat 5b yeah
this is really exciting that's right
it's you ma'am you are getting a new car
[Music]
[Applause]
here's the catch you only get to keep
the car if you can drive it out of our
studio in under 30 seconds right now
live on the show and go
[Applause]
[Applause]
see baby I told you it would work now
let's go rob some liquor stores
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you